what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and i know a lot of
people are wondering like me where the
heck is that thor love and thunder
trailer don't worry you are not alone
but unfortunately it looks like we might
not have some good news on the trailer
front and it looks like thor loving
thunder could also be in jeopardy of
possibly being delayed dc just shifted
their entire slate for 2022 and a lot of
people are wondering and are kind of
afraid that marvel might do the same but
i'll break down everything that you need
to know in this video and of course if
you love marvel and you want to stay up
to date on the mcu be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos now unfortunately even if
thor love and thunder doesn't end up
getting delayed due to these reshoots it
still might affect the teaser trailer so
taikawa tt came out last week in an
interview and stated that the film thor
love and thunder is not done yet thor
tell me everything there's nothing left
after i've said everything for the last
two years it's still not finished it's
not finished when is it gonna be
finished it comes out in july so
probably the end of june
like a day before the premiere that's
how we do it
now a lot of people thought that he was
kidding but i did not think that he was
kidding even though we're kind of in the
latter half of the pandemic we're still
in a pandemic and they're still taking a
lot of safety precautions and people are
still getting sick getting coveted and
this can make it very complicated for
the studios especially when they are
filming and today we kind of have some
good news but also bad news now we'll
talk about the bad news first get that
out of the way then talk about the good
news but the bad news is that according
to a report from the rap thor love and
thunder is about to do some reshoots in
the next couple of weeks now some people
are worried about this and some people
think that this means that the movie
could be delayed tycho recently said
that he'll probably finish the movie
right before the premiere and now
they've announced that reshoots are
coming if this report by the rap is
accurate now doctor strange the
multiverse of madness underwent
extensive reshoots and they only delayed
the film just a little bit and we're not
even sure if that's why indeed they
delayed the film so this isn't a
guaranteed delay although this does
probably affect the release of that
teaser trailer if they are trying to get
some key shots in we might have to wait
a few weeks for them to get this
additional photography if they want to
use some of these key scenes in the
teaser trailer and a lot of fans right
now are worried about a shift in the
entire marvel schedule there are some
signs that that could be a possibility
but i don't think that's going to happen
and i'll explain why but first big thank
you to hellofresh for sponsoring today's
video if you are like me and you don't
really know how to cook you don't really
have time to cook but you love a fresh
home cooked meal hellofresh is for you
hellofresh is america's number one meal
kit delivery service offering the widest
variety of recipes and they're quick and
easy to make seriously you can save time
and stress i'm using hellofresh right
now to help me hit my fitness goals with
fit and wholesome recipes you can
indulge in delicious meals without the
worries making health and weight loss
easier but don't worry these foods are
delicious and with over 50 weekly menu
items you can choose from including
pescetarian and veggie options there's a
wide variety of extremely delicious food
and seriously if me and my other youtube
friends can make this food anyone can
they lay it all out for you in simple
steps so use my link or go to
hellofresh.com and use code pog cosmic
w16 for up to 16 free meals plus three
surprise gifts across six hellofresh
boxes plus free shipping now what really
scared people recently is that dc warner
brothers they shifted their entire
release schedule for 2022. they just
announced some really big delays and
fans are pretty worried that marvel
studios might do the same thing
especially with all of these rumors
about reshoots not only for multiverse
of madness but now for thor love and
thunder and there's been a lot of talk
about black panther 2 wakanda forever
they've ran into a lot of speed bumps
while filming this movie and again
there's fear that this might actually
get pushed back however in a recent
article by the cosmiccircus.com
it has been stated that even though
black panther 2 wakanda forever has been
through a lot it does appear to be on
track to finish when they expected to
finish and it seems like things are
really on track now so no need to worry
about that so it doesn't look like
there's going to be a shift in the
entire schedule i don't think doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness is
going to be delayed anymore i think we
have a locked in date i think that is
going to be may 6th for sure after this
we're supposed to get thor love and
thunder and then miss marvel my only
fear here is that they might swap miss
marvel and thor love and thunder now
this is just speculation on my part this
has not been reported by any outlet
however there was a report that the next
trailer that we would be getting would
be for miss marvel which is very
interesting considering the fact that
thor love and thunder comes out before
miss marvel we have a tiny teaser for
miss marvel including some clips that
have been shown at disney plus day and
recently disney investor day but we
don't have anything for thor love and
thunder yet now miss marvel is only
going to be six episodes long and we
know that disney plus shows can interlap
with movies so i would hope that if they
did switch the release dates for them it
wouldn't really be that big of a
difference maybe a month at the most
again this is just speculation and let's
hope that there really aren't any delays
for thor love and thunder and the good
news is that when tyka talked about
finishing the movie he said that this is
pretty much how it always is and they
actually did this with avengers infinity
war and avengers end game they finished
the final cuts for the movies right
before the release dates right before
the worldwide premieres sometimes this
is just how things go and oftentimes
it's actually good news because they're
doing all that they can to make the
movie look the best that it can so
fortunately for us i don't think we
should be expecting any more delays
although i will add that it certainly is
possible especially if they go back to
do reshoots and they decide that they
actually need even more but taika watiti
has been pretty confident that this next
film is going to be really really big
and really really awesome and he has a
lot of confidence in that which probably
means that what they have so far is
pretty dang good and they don't need a
ton of reshoots so i think we can rest
easy on the delays but unfortunately
that doesn't really give us much news
about the trailer because if they need
those shots from the reshoots for the
teaser trailer it'll probably get
delayed a couple of weeks now fingers
crossed that it still shows up this
month sometime but again it all depends
on if they need some of these shots from
the reshoots now for those worried about
an entire shift of the schedule because
also miss marvel has been doing reshoots
as well again i don't think we should
really panic i don't think marvel is
looking to shift the entire schedule
they have right now i think individual
projects are just going back for
reshoots it's good that they're each
going back for reshoots and it's not
pandemic related because if it were
pandemic related then we might expect an
entire shift but fortunately for us the
good news is that each of these projects
are kind of individually based the
reshoots have to do with those projects
not with other stuff going on and it
looks like fortunately everything is
still kind of on track despite going
through reshoots and keep in mind the
studios typically plan on doing reshoots
they kind of just add that time in there
so they don't cut it too close so often
this is plan four so even though dc
shifted their entire schedule i don't
think marvel is looking to do the same i
just think that they're trying to make
the best movies that they can but of
course unfortunately this does not help
us when figuring out when that thor love
and thunder trailer is but of course if
i hear anything i'll be sure to let you
know and do an update video in the
meantime don't forget to subscribe and
hit that bell so you can stay up to date
on all of the latest mcu news don't
forget to like the video and of course
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you